Lord gang floor welcome to Wakanda the
Utopia the greatest place on earth so
this is my place in Animal Crossing if
you're not familiar with Animal Crossing
I'm sure you know someone that's been
obsessed with this game lately I saw my
Chet play this and I was like that's the
dumbest that's the dumbest thing I've
ever seen
no one's know we're never gonna play
that game but she convinced me to
download it and yes I am hooked yes I
love it so this is my city this is what
Conda welcome to Wakanda please give me
free stuff if you're playing this game
and tell me what your turnip prices are
so I put these streets in I downloaded
the streets but I designed these yellow
ones so it's like Japan because I love
Japan I think it's pretty cool I try to
give it like a urban feel to it this is
one of the first items I have glorious
Statue of Liberty very nice so this is
actually my real character the problem
is I bought a switch light but you can't
record on switch lights I have to record
with this character it's so dumb got my
drinks if I need one it's all G fuel in
case you're wondering I think there is
actual G fuel in this game people I've
been liking me like G fuel and stuff I
feel like if I video makes no sense if
you don't play Animal Crossing but we
are going to visit my dad later I just
want to show off my island first so this
is basically it
I even try to get my mom to play this
game but she said that the characters
speak too annoying for her so yeah it's
not it's I like it I think it's cool
it's got a good feel it makes me feel
good this game is very very very
addicting these are my villagers this is
sherbert best friends
he's just pretending because I'm this
not my character this road ends here but
we're working on it basically I started
playing this pretty late so if you're
judging me it's because yeah I was late
I was a late bloomer in this game and
now I'm paying the consequences because
everyone is like years ahead this is the
beach here's our turtle he sells
seashells normally but I needed the
seashell so I took them from him his
name is Sven I'm just kidding can I
enter these by the way Oh sad alright
here's the duck I don't like him all my
villagers are basically sociopath
do you not normally just stare set the
grass and that's all he or she ever does
I don't know what it is to be honest in
here we have my animal crossing normally
she loves me okay it's cuz I'm someone
else whenever I hear might say used to
heart emoji which is playing with other
people I have to ask her where she's
doing it to I gotta be sure all right
let's put Brent we also have my house to
show
[Music]
who else do we have this game is like so
fun to play but it's so frustrating at
the same time if you played through
Easter you know exactly what I'm talking
about oh my god what an introduction
snakes hobbies is weightlifting a lot of
them are but it's funny he's also asking
me like what's your favorite workout and
then he judges me based on my work I'm
super weird it's really fun interacting
with the villagers in this game
for those who you don't know I don't
have a flag yet I'm not the white flag
is not what we're doing I know that's
kind of ironic to be what kind of it but
that's not what we're doing
oh yeah I have the weirdest villager
ever all he does is sing in the middle
of the night all grace is crafting cool
that means I get a recipe look at this
house those give me a recipe wooden
double bed okay I'll take yes yes just
give it to me I wanted to give like the
amazing furniture years look at this
house dude give me some of that gamer
bread I need it I'm not watching
villagers isn't the most interesting
well get to my house eventually this is
my tour later in the game you get to
change the world like you get to move
water and make mountains and stuff so
I'm planning to put a house here and a
house here it's just that I can't do it
right now
and I want everything to be symmetric I
spent so much time and money for
everything to be perfectly symmetric if
you don't put it perfectly the first
time if you're new playing make sure you
put it perfectly otherwise you're
screwed you'll regret it
don't listen to only one I got this rich
Emperor
Klaus moving in so it's a different I
think there's a hundred different
villager so it's kind of fun seeing them
all I just got this lighthouse I know
pretty epic
this is my fishing bridge very nice it's
my happy place
the bear yes there's a Roman guy can you
go to your house so I can show off your
house Klaus is rude oh is that his name
you have a beautiful love Fountain Park
with some lights it's very pretty at
night and then over here I'm planning to
have the temple I'm planning to build
all this out I have big plans okay I
have big plans it's all coming together
and then I have this little spring area
with the pagoda it's pretty cool this
one at first items I got I was so happy
I think yeah the only thing left to show
it's my house really it's so funny when
Jack told me about this game it was like
oh animal crossing you should play it
it's so fun and relaxing no wait it's
not anyone that tells your animal
crossing is relaxing liar the game has
mortgage it has stock market so these
turnips are basically the stock market
of the game you can't keep them in your
inventory that's yeah oh my god it's all
turnips yeah I'm I'm playing the turnip
game okay but just imagine that is
normally a really cool okay and then
don't even get me started on the stress
with eastern imagine you're playing an
RPG and you're trying to level up but
all the sudden the game introduces RPG
Easter mode and then everything that
gets you XP it's just cut in half
because instead you get eggs what are
the eggs do a bunch of garbage it's all
turnips basically for now please if you
have good turnip prices let me know
because I have my entire life saving on
the line here on the turnips if the
turnips doesn't work out I'm out of a
job all right I can't I cannot let this
happen
yeah I'm just planning to build it all
out but Canada is going to be the
greatest country in the world it's a
completely free society hence the Statue
of Liberty there's no rules there's no
laws you know how long it took for me to
put on these tiles okay you better enjoy
it
right I have to go individually and put
them all down was it worth it
absolutely okay let me check it back in
wisdom icing mindset can I visit you now
I never seen my sis so invested in
anything in her life as this game I
don't know what it is well how the bells
ring that's how I know what time it is
now I don't check my watch I play animal
crossing here's a big fish
see what we get and I got the long boy
with Jack during his life she was
hilarious she bet it's at least C+
that's how I raised thank you oh my god
all right the snapper
it's looking what I caught a red snapper
it looks pretty dapper that's funny do
you like my outfit by the rank Swedish
Viking duck thing I think it's pretty
cool this is the most low-key video I've
done a long time police much like so I
feel better by myself thank you funny
things doctor outfit I gotta buy
everything a doctor outfit that's kind
of tempting it makes me so uncomfortable
when he makes a new post stop ooh that's
kind of hot okay oh it gets better
yeah I'm getting this definitely
definitely I don't have a room god damn
it this is your fart night this is your
fault Mabel look she follows you around
in this store accent all right yes you
learn
this game is so relaxing you should play
this game now we're ready to visit
Marcia thank you the Mabel for nothing
all right so be nice and say nice thing
to might say a lot of nice comments okay
this is very important my life depends
on it
okay so we're flying over picky picky
she owns a snake as a villager
temperatures comfortable oh dude she's
got kanji on there
oh she is look at Sookie oh she has the
same dress in the game is real life
every time Martha comes to me she has a
different outfit she's always on point I
gotta give her props I mean so do i but
she doesn't know that yet can't wait to
hear a reaction okay wait she probably
has something prepared but so do i I
have a tambourine but she doesn't know
hello curlies welcome to thank you she
only makes that emergent to me no one
else okay
all right watch me there look at this
whoa look at this can I don't even get
out foot oh cool hair thank you
okay I want some coconut drinks that's
so cute
[Music]
we have the same hair how did I get this
hair nice this is peak animal crossing
gameplay happening you don't understand
very cute
I like the road I like the little trucks
admire tiny champers I can't make emojis
I give them one little sponge each there
you go oh look see if she can make some
waterfalls and stuff I can't do that
it's not fair it's not theater that's
cool sign actually I don't
apparently this isn't good made today I
like a why she just has to try a shot
what if I just pull open sweet look at
that I think you drew that oh my gosh
you definitely drew these yes okay yes
please
you get goody bags and picky picky I'll
take it
join what do we get oh nice oh hell yeah
who's this
you have no pants on oh my god he's my
boy oh my god I knew it
stop okay what else you got amazing
of course my wife's Italian so you gotta
have those Italian pizzas for continued
Hana
let's flower nice
or sucky months oh my god what
well I'm so good at it no more Tiger
drugs I drew it
I can tell all right so this is the play
for kids area very nice nice I like the
I like the cherry blossom cute well
picnic area I could play my tambourine
here oh my god the Bears whoa I never
seen the moon before the chief says
cheating she's cheating my ex he
actually wanted me to make sure to say
that she has not been to that people
online have been accusing her of
cheating but she has not and I can
confirm that she has she plays 24 hours
basically I'm actually scared look she's
got her turned it's all organized oh
that's the witch oh yeah I know you can
say how did the dog hold up its Edgar
Edgar lives in there another picnic area
this is where she writes fanfic about
you and the bear is a long long boy
betrayed me I knew it is a tough life
yeah you know spin around oh yeah I can
look around yeah
amazing what a cool time oh hell
abort abort game aboard no no how do the
toilet opens by itself we truly are
living a utopia oh there we go oh my god
that's what it would look like if I went
on in the toilet basically oh my god she
even customized the fan that's detail
that's crap
oh my god what is this this is the
massage room what is this
nice peaceful peace at last oh this is a
bedroom
why is there a single bed where do I
sleep sorry I live here now oh she's a
bird sometime I'm gonna pretend I didn't
hear that whoa look at that
that's soaked oh my god that's a raccoon
guy no I don't like him can he leave oh
my god
he made these they look great they look
so tasty
no wonder Mars is always poor she has so
many items Jesus Christ oh my god it's
so big up here I would have to give this
four time brain Saida for are we going
to the Bears now yeah I'm a little
scared I'm not gonna lie I was dating
say I'm not terrified okay where's she
yeah all right we have keemstar nice
yes so much more to show them this could
have been it's an episode on its own
you connect this is so anime I'm
blessing it with my tambourine oh my god
that's a big ban
hello hi Bear Paw Paw Paw Paw Paw bless
my states officially more gamer than I
am it's been proven yeah it's that ok
Yama's on alright can I hit the gong
yeah oh my god it's so great bait
[Music]
amazing it's like we're in Japan which
we were supposed to be that's like big
oh good still ahead
oh my god I ordered a good Scylla I
don't have it yet I'm scared oh my god
oh my god
Wow amazing you paying your respects
oh he plays a music I don't know oh my
god that's so cool is this my cue to
leave bless their cars
no more who stays never seen her
alright I'll call mom and I tell her to
start playing this game come on mom my
mom has been playing Legend of Zelda for
like 400 hours so this is where all the
villagers how she got a bus station I
wanted that it never comes that's why
they alright cute oh yeah this is her
Potter area chicken lips ooh where nice
where's chicken
[Music]
oh my god
oh wow Thank You chicken everyone that
plays this game puts their size up to
8,000 whoa that's so creepy I didn't
know you could do this listen there's
nothing I'm rattled
[Music]
[Music]
oh you get potions and stuff I mean
they're not potions recipes if you need
thank you but it's my other accounts I
don't need them thank you thank you okay
so that's Animal Crossing for you right
there
oh why she kicked me out really thanks
thanks okay so that's Animal Crossing
for you if you enjoy this video hit the
gently click on the like button and
maybe we'll do another one of these a
little bit further along and that's it
see you tomorrow
Hado hey
I got to play more element crossing